[Music]
welcome back to the hero daily my name
is demons this is uh super bowl sunday
and it looks like we are getting those
two trailers from moon knight and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness i
am so excited about this because the
rumors have been swirling for multiverse
of madness with the cameos the
possibility of bringing back characters
that we haven't seen in honestly over a
decade i am i'm ecstatic i hope that we
we see just a little bit more from the
movie just to keep us going until march
and then we have moon knight with their
amazing trailer that everyone was
looking forward to
if you guys don't remember marvel has a
history with the super bowl commercials
last year they did show us
the
loki trailer they showed us the the
little teaser for um
i should say teasers because they were
teasers it was a teaser for one division
loki and
falcon in the winter soldier which were
just enough to to keep us going as mcu
fans because it was such a dry year uh
before that and
um
this year i know people have been
very much blessed with the amount of
projects that we've gotten from the mcu
and it almost seems like
the projects that we didn't get in 2020
obviously are kind of overflowing into
2021 and 2022
and i think that's what we're seeing
this year we have a ton of projects
coming out this year it's a great time
to be an mcu fan
i'm ecstatic for the future of the mcu
we have so much coming i know uh we got
the x-men coming we have a fantastic
four coming it's it's gonna be amazing
from here forward
um
let me know in the comments what are you
guys looking forward to the most uh with
this trailer are you guys hoping that we
see
maybe a cameo that we were rumored to
have or are you just trying to see more
of the movie itself just to keep you
going uh to be fair please comment down
below like this video if you did and uh
subscribe if you can
i am doing this every day i am barely
getting started here uh this is i think
my fifth episode uh and i'm not stopping
anytime soon so um yeah again please
turn notifications i i am doing this
every day see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you